أنت تعرف وإلى حد كبير في أي وقت
رأينا فيه متغيرًا جديدًا ، إنه منتشر بالفعل في
جميع أنحاء العالم ، لذا فإن حقيقة أن
omicron في بلدان متعددة في
أوروبا في الولايات المتحدة ليست بالضرورة
علامة مشؤومة وأعتقد أن هذه
نقطة أساسية  ضع في اعتبارك وتذكر أيضًا
أننا لم نر أي دليل على
أن omicron ينتج
مرضًا
أكثر خطورة من أي من المتغيرات الأخرى ،
هناك نقطة أخرى يجب وضعها في الاعتبار والآن فيما
يتعلق بما إذا كان
هذا المتغير
سيقاوم المناعة أم لا
من الممكن أن تكون الاستجابة لقاحاتنا الحالية ممكنة ولكن من غير المحتمل أن تكون
مقاومة تمامًا وقد تكون
مقاومة جزئيًا تمامًا مثل المتغيرات الأخرى التي
رأيناها مثل
b1351 من جنوب إفريقيا ، تذكر أن
أحد المتغيرات بيتا ومتغير لامدا
لذلك وغير ذلك أبدًا
أقلعت أه على الرغم من وجود الكثير من
الطفرات الأخرى المتعلقة
ببروتين السنبلة لذا سنعرف عن مدى
فعالية اللقاحات لأننا نستطيع
إجراء اختبار ما يمكنك القيام به
هو القياس  استجابات الأجسام المضادة
للقاحات إما في حيوانات المختبر أو
من المرضى الذين
تم تحصينهم ضد اللقاحات أو المتطوعين الذين تم تحصينهم
ومعرفة ما إذا كانت هذه
الأجسام المضادة ستعمل على تحييد
متغير أوميكرون وسنعرف ذلك على
الأرجح بحلول الأسبوع المقبل في هذا الوقت أو
في غضون  الأسبوعين المقبلين ، لذلك
سيكون هذا جزءًا حيويًا من المعلومات ،
على سبيل المثال
، يبحث الآن علماءنا في مستشفى الأطفال في تكساس وبايلور
في ذلك بالضبط أو
الاستجابة المناعية للقاح لدينا لمعرفة ما إذا كان سيؤدي إلى
تحييد الأوميكرون بشكل متقاطع ، لذلك
سيكون  نقطة أساسية
، وبعد ذلك سنكون أهم
شيء نحتاج إلى
معرفته الآن هو مدى قابلية انتقال هذا
البديل ، نعم لقد تم نقله
في المقاطعة التي تحتوي على
بريتوريا وجوهانسبرغ
ولكن هل يكفي للتنافس على
متغير دلتا و  لا أعتقد حقًا أن
لدينا دليلًا قويًا على ذلك ،
لذا فأنت تعلم بعد أسبوع من الآن إذا أجرينا
هذه المناقشة ، فسيكون لدينا الكثير من
المعلومات ولكن  في الوقت الحالي ، أعتقد أنه من
المهم التركيز على ما
نعرف أنه أكبر تهديد في
الولايات المتحدة وهذا هو متغير دلتا الذي
يتسارع الآن
وسكان الولايات المتحدة غير محصنين بشكل كامل